we are out here in the Persian Gulf with
the US Military and this might look like
a normal boat but it is actually a drone
boat
just a few yards away more than a dozen
other state-of-the-art robots that are
expected to completely change the nature
of surveillance and Warfare on the water
we are getting a rare look at The
Cutting Edge technology the U.S is
testing technology that other nations
are competing to develop too well right
now we're on the Leading Edge of it and
our goal is to stay on the Leading Edge
here in Bahrain a U.S Navy Team known as
task force 59 has created a test bed for
some of the latest and greatest
commercially made Marine drones
the drones here aren't armed for now
they're loaded with high-tech radios
cameras radar and all kinds of other
sensors to help expand the Navy's eyes
and ears in the ocean there are more
than a dozen unmanned platforms being
tested by the Navy as part of an effort
to develop the world's first big
unmanned Fleet of these boats
we're using a model which I just call a
factory to Fleet this is vice admiral
Brad Cooper he established task force 59
to rapidly integrate unmanned technology
and artificial intelligence we're
bringing things here very quickly and
then testing them in the environment
that would ultimately serve and quickly
determining can they show promise and be
effective in this environment because
it's a tough environment here in the
Middle East from this Navy base in
Bahrain vice admiral Cooper commands the
fifth Fleet which covers some of the
most dynamic dangerous and commercially
important Waters in the world there are
three key choke points here all vital to
the global supply chain there are also a
number of hostile actors most notably
Iran which poses all kinds of Maritime
threats in recent months the Navy has
seen record drug and weapon seizures
including from boats traveling from Iran
to Yemen with large amounts of explosive
material ammunition rocket fuses and
AK-47s and that has all been since the
Navy has put some of the drones into to
operation ensuring Maritime security
here is job one for us a key aspect of
that is understanding what's happening
on the water and this is where these
unmanned systems and artificial
intelligence can be helpful
all right you ready I'm ready to see
those unmanned systems being tested in
an exercise called digital Horizon we
climbed into a rigid whole inflatable
boat or a rib here it goes doors opening
and dropped out of the back of a Coast
Guard Cutter to get closer to the action
it was sort of like a drone Safari
so this is the Triton and it is both a
surface vessel and an underwater vessel
we saw what's hailed as the only vehicle
that can Sail on the surface and also
operate in submarine mode all right so
that is the martek
we also saw autonomous speed boats like
this Interceptor which can travel more
than 80 miles per hour
and small solar-powered vessels capable
of collecting information on the water
for months at a time according to the
companies that make them there was also
this larger boat which can deploy
smaller robots to detect and neutralize
mines and submarines
see this photo that's us the drone on
its own flagged our boat as a Potential
Threat all right so on some of these
boats you see a big green box and that
box actually houses an aerial drone the
Navy's goal is to use these drones sort
of Stack these drones together so that
they can extend the Navy's eyes and ears
out in the ocean farther and farther
this so-called drone in a box was tested
on top of a few different drone boats
this vertical launch drone took off and
landed for the first time in windy
conditions from the small deck of a
Coast Guard ship
the drones are all connected by Silvis
radios creating a resilient mesh network
if one boat goes down the mesh Network
self heals and continues working the
aerial drones extend that Network even
further which can help enable Over the
Horizon operations this network allows
all of the drones to relay everything
they're seeing and sensing back to the
Navy's robotics operations center or The
Rock
well welcome to the rock this is where
we bring together all the data and all
the sensor information this is Captain
Michael brasser Commodore of task force
59 he's in charge of overseeing top
talent from the Navy we're pulling in
you know track data from AIS from Radars
from the cameras and bringing Together
commercial drone companies which are
competitors to help the Navy see what's
going on on the water you see a few
streams of live video so this is
happening right now the Navy is able to
visualize everything the drones are
picking up with the help of Partners
like Accenture Federal services and Big
Bear AI
and here's where things get really
interesting by harvesting millions of
data points coming in from the drones
they're able to learn normal patterns of
life in the ocean so that they can
recognize when things are off we're
talking about data Cloud compute machine
learning Ai and when all of those come
together you start to get in the
predictive space the end state is an
understanding of the environment so rich
that we're anticipating things to happen
so we can prevent them from happening
defense experts tell me the need for
this kind of technology has become
clearer in the wake of the war in
Ukraine and escalating tensions over
Taiwan in the past year we've seen how
Russian ships go dark to skirt sanctions
internet cables running along the seabed
LIE vulnerable and critical underwater
gas pipelines can be damaged we've also
seen claims of armed unmanned vessels
operating in Ukraine in October Russia
said Ukrainian drone boats attacked its
warships on the Black Sea that attack
involves nine unmanned terrible vehicles
and seven autonomous Maritime drones
United 24 a Ukrainian group close to
president zielinski praised the attack
and began crowdfunding for more Naval
drones while the U.S Navy isn't
currently arming these commercial drone
boats some of the Drone companies say
they've already developed those
capabilities yeah so Siegel is the only
unmanned surface vehicle in the world
that has actually launched the torpedo
so the Arabian Fox is a multi-mission
capable platform it is capable of
carrying a variety of payloads to
include weapons system yet before most
of the work that we've been doing on the
platform was focused on that
intelligence Mission set and now we're
starting to look at some other kinetic
options
analysts expect the use of drone boats
to explode worldwide in the coming years
not just because of their capabilities
but because they offer militaries a way
to cut costs and reduce risk to human
life check out this chart it shows the
approximate growth of the unmanned
aerial Vehicles market and right here is
when uavs were taking off compare that
to the growth of the unmanned Marine
Vehicles Market which emerged more than
a decade later the data suggests that
the growth rates are similar other
countries are racing to catch up with
the United States in June China's
state-run media published video of its
first drone Mothership completing an
autonomous trial Russia has been working
on a nuclear-tipped underwater drone
called the Poseidon and Turkish
officials have touted unmanned surface
vehicles that can swarm on their own the
technology is evolving but
confrontations have already begun
these videos show an Iranian ship towing
a U.S drone boat back in August Iranian
media said it impounded the Drone to
secure safe shipping lanes as you put
more unmanned vessels in the water does
the potential for conflict increase yeah
I think it's first important to note
that from our interaction with Iran that
their actions were flagrant they were
unwanted their actions were a violation
of international law beyond that we have
not changed our operating patterns the
United States Navy and our partners fly
and sail with international law allows
and that's what we'll continue to do in
the future as for the near future the
secretary of the Navy said he said Force
59's efforts will be replicated in other
hot spots and we will soon expand that
capability to other regions of the world
which is Central and South America and
the indo-pacific
and in the Middle East new task forces
in the Army and Air Force are working
alongside task force 59 with unmanned
ground vehicles and aircraft and that
helps the Navy and the U.S military
broadly see ocean floor to space
absolutely see bed to space integrating
sensors in the most dynamic vibrant way
that we can
all right guys if you want to see more
from my interview with vice admiral Brad
Cooper check out this video I'll see you
next time